[Musik]
sind
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur verließ welt
heute gibt es ein leckeres grill rezept
wir werden hinten teile vom grill
zubereiten
die sind wirklich super lecker und
richtig würzig und ich würde sage ich
zeit mich auch gleich die zutaten denn
das rezept ist wirklich super einfach
dafür brauche ich einfach hinten teile
und zwar etwa 16 hinten flügel und zwar
hähnchenschenkel die nämlich gleich
auseinander
salz und pfeffer 50 milliliter
sonnenblumenöl oder apfel hier die
zutaten für die marinade 4
knoblauchzehen zwei chilischoten 50
milliliter war ja bloß weil es dass
honig den saft funktionierten eine prise
cayennepfeffer und einen esslöffel
paprikapulver ich nehme jetzt zuerst
einmal die hähnchenteile und zwar nehme
ich jetzt nichts schenken und die werde
ich jetzt hier trennen
aber das ungelenk internet das nehme ich
jetzt hier einmal aufeinander
[Musik]
kann man allerdings um teile in eine
große schüssel da kommt jetzt das öl mit
dazu und dann braucht ihr auf jeden fall
in öl welches man hoch erhitzen kann
dass er auf den grill kommt jetzt
reichlich salz und pfeffer und je
nachdem wie gut die ersten drei vier
portionen jetzt für zwei bis vier
sechser auf würde ich jetzt mal sagen
vor allem kommt drauf an ob einer
beilage gibt obgleich noch anderes
beispiel wird von daher müsst ihr
einfach selber schauen wie viele da bin
[Musik]
damit ist gut durchgemischt
jetzt ist das fleisch gut durchgemischt
und anders als bei dem zum beispiel kann
ich das hähnchenfleisch auch wirklich
vor dem grillen schon mit salz und
pfeffer würzen
es wird dadurch nicht trocken ich werde
jetzt die hähnchenteile allerdings nicht
mit der marinade bestreichen den
ansonsten kann es einfach passieren was
die marinade zu schnell verbrennt wenn
hähnchen braucht auf dem grill schon ein
bisschen länger und muss vor allem
komplett durchgegart werden will muss
zuerst einmal die großen hähnchenteile
die frauen den dritten länger das heißt
die hähnchenschenkel sinne zuerst an der
reihe und ich werde dann zuerst etwas
angriff so dass einfach die röstaromen
entstehen und dann aber auch die zweite
packen so dass sie einfach bei ihnen
direkt vor hitze weiter kam nach etwa 15
minuten kommen dann die flügel mit otto
die brauchen nämlich nicht ganz so lange
und dann nach 15 minuten also nach
insgesamt 30 minuten werde ich die
marinade drüber machen und die können
wir einfach in der zwischenzeit zu
bereiten
die hähnchenteile waren jetzt insgesamt
eine halbe stunde auf dem grill und
jetzt kann ich die marinade zu bereiten
das heißt ich hab hier der schlüssel da
gebe ich jetzt so wowereit
dann auch den limettensaft
[Musik]
auch der honig sind rein statt honig
könnte zum beispiel auch agaven dicksaft
oder auch und sirup verwenden
einfach köstlich nehmen paprikapulver
und cayenne und jetzt die chili die hab
ich jetzt fallen und die knoblauchzehen
die reibe ich davor
[Musik]
ganze wirklich natürlich auch noch mit
salz und pfeffer
[Musik]
den knoblauch gebe ich jetzt ganz zum
schluss dass ihm ein foto aus nämlich
heute mit dabei und da verträgt keinen
knoblauch und daher nehme ich jetzt ein
bisschen was von der marinade weg und
dann kommt erst der knoten
[Musik]
ein
jetzt immer noch draussen und da kann
ich die hähnchenteile damit zu streichen
[Musik]
jetzt sind diejenigen teile fertig und
ich finde den wundervoll aus und vor
allen dingen richtig lecker windows xp
sowohl in den haag zu probieren ja ich
hab kommen lassen damit du dich nicht
verbremst an dem hunderte zwischen
grafik
die echte keine flügel und lieben ja ich
mag am liebsten okay dann probier ich
habe dazu ganz grill untypisch aber ich
habe trotzdem gemacht denn man rudolph
heute zur gas- und die kinder wollen ja
auch erst habe ich türkischen reich
gemacht
ich kann es probieren also hier richtig
cool
ok ich probiert ob er wohl fühlen
und was sagen die menschen dafür streng
sind drin
vorher wurde und knoblauch zwischendurch
ist auch ganz wichtig bei hähnchen dafür
ganz durchdreht und das ist gerade in so
sauer oder vorsätzlich oder ist genial
und wieder machen
wie gesagt falls ihr das machen möchte
dann beachtet auf jeden fall die tipps
ich euch hier in dem video gegeben habt
habe also im prinzip zuerst das fleisch
anbraten später erst die marinade drauf
und vor allem gut durchgaren und falls
ihr das präsent nachlesen möchte dann
könnt ihr auch fällig - lockte ihn
nachschauen und ich wünsche euch jetzt
mal ganz viel spaß danach machen und bis
zum nächsten mal zum 19
er überlegt welches genug dafür andere
er ist ein fucking hell
ich hab noch mal um welche braucht
[Musik]